[Music]
the tradition 2 option nardis ready for
of the category became sinar
the reason for this role vision trimax our
worldwide
je black as a skill and so the notion
of art is witsel use our time you say
the archies mad king of the art of
disney hardware and soda gadget for
drawbar
wed of the stones becomes artwork argument
in love comes from the nose in a
fitting things together
zo de capacité sitting together properly
dat word art kids
en zo in the traditional vision of art
million saving
like a the art forum  a jihadist at
the guard is the skill the viking tanks and
so that object that is made a few
server purpose so that this system in
the regional vision from smeking art
door mee card you start to make thinks and
so the martians the tool
ardis the tool  artis de skill artis de the
abilities jihad master to make an
object and so wenda dips not to
hme function the new world needs to be
integrated within and propose an
in-depth profi won the hard stingy
ball t  e support is once
to a valley win it self and which
one the steeper lidwina jan the student
in action liberated miami
van de la prad be developed
planning bureau is really scary is with art is
this argan oil you they come up with some
crazy
jeff  koons gino blown up snoopy and then
the machines is dark and the answer to
mina has become a 10 times led the this
mare
let's not to point on twitter the arbor
to this snap that of a tassel
question is there is that in mather this in
her  opinion
so having [ __ ] is it is it
integrative already meanwhile side i like this
in him kh looks integrate into the
world and so wild is math panorama hdrt
well tender finite en de ages so
family cost you was so taking them that
became the  subject of my garden
oh so object by martin koolen just
how can i make up in this post modern
world which is after it is harley quinn
action
connecting to the family that
tour-tour-tour the tea coffee world you
meet with  a u was your the silent thing again
presumably
and imitate you took May 18 will frederik en
doen and you so funny people the last my
last day in school en naja supervisor
was greame my final grade
shared a use of a relaxing finished
first in my program  can jury
diligence is now hardback she knew
that was used to working and kia cee'd
is limit shadow permit once you get
it okay the china is now working
with i understood and yet more
einstein you should go for double tibia
christen person  who is mad king art in
a manner which were as en jack en wat
we still some hoop harder de
contemporary art world which full
marnie in full of de wol politics double
removal and constant
quinoa i can get a flyby scoop
synoviale the sea jazz within it wasn  it's going to
be a happening
and so you see so see is tommy another
life day of my mine that explains exactly
how they do here the title
your goal the long here moving through the
seminar there sand in a youtube show
lobi c  oaches can see the class in that
[ __ ] [ __ ] naked
this is something I think with the
white contemporary world
justin have place the person such as
socials the youtuber that matter of a
european where is a piece of art no no
not a yes that is  dan thick the mri is already
something can sandusky the problem was mostly
to say how can a great as part of the
community
the teleporter chris a community
also keep an imac
object which it into my life and into my
world and in to motivate that in a  in
an integrated way i do like any this
italian differ between aydin nice
picasso and
discovery to the shark really is the
difference between lid c
imac
you're a musician and you can't i made
in usa us why use land
winter  i am hi ah hi designing the
car for your party que le niet dat
traditio hard to and the pot of a
version of walibi
de vos myers that wat we die i will make
and guitar that will question why the
guitar is a highly guitar that i  can
never go  nna be played with wil
wil ironically glass in the gold edition
word of widgetized in in with music and
and den aperitif in north and south side is
so keep the heart itself is an
object how they grow choose a fly-by-
wire oh wow historical  keep archive
sit house thea and hijack which may
the force two words that the
pepe difficulty on us marlies to push so that
as long as we deslaado is
home i know that we
would we find you tried to
create alone
visual language must be
integrate with marjan expires with my
party with my hand participates in in
the community in the church in all
[Music]